[Music]
real quick uh who in this room
do we all collectively think is the most
like either just degenerate delinquent
uh in in their high school days
in my high school days he said my reveal
i think it's a tie between these two for
high school degenerate day i don't know
maybe did you guys ever like break into
houses and do [ __ ] did what'd you guys
do but that wasn't in high school none
of
them lawns
hey you forked lawns dude i was fine you
did something
big time by the way that's senior prank
different
that's that's a prank
different category
what did you guys do when you broke into
houses
stole
oh
he's like just a regular petty theft you
know
so um a bunch of teens recently
broke into an 8 million dollar florida
mansion
in order to party and hold boxing
matches
okay
i'm listening
where's the dobermans at those those
mansions got those dolores come out bite
people yeah where's the brick security
at you know where's the brink stober
the golf cart yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and how did they know it was empty bunch
of hooligans and the wet sprinklers to
make everyone slip and fall eight
million dollar house that's correct all
right here we go here we go here we go
let's get a little video here we got a
video what this house looks like
whoa
yikes
holy [ __ ] god damn
damn
people love fights is it like all high
school kids teens all teenagers
apparently that looks like a good party
it looks like a good party right like a
lot of good people it's not your house
you're not gonna break anything it's not
yours
that's kind of gene like that's kind of
bold
in high school like
being that bold
it's brave a [ __ ]
mansion yeah that's scary i knew this
guy would give props right away
that's so crazy
i mean the the most that we've done
is like let's go sister use a pool
of
like if you look into someone's backyard
they're like that's a dope pool and then
you just like see that they're not home
and then you jump in and you use that
pull
i mean the criminal stuff is different
that's the criminal stuff is like yeah i
mean that's that's hardcore the pool's
also like you know like break into the
house you're breaking out the outside of
the house yeah yeah you like hop the
backyard fence and some [ __ ] and then
they get over my pool and you're like
[ __ ] just wet and just running out
the cops i mean like the owners may not
call the cops if they saw yeah i
probably wouldn't like i don't know
that's weird if you got away you'd be
like ah i'd actually be a kid worried
about the kids like running and [ __ ]
up pretty hard yeah i just be like hey
guys just get out and go this way don't
hop the fans and you know like don't
give your parents a reason to sue me
yeah like yeah yeah yeah for real i
remember just [ __ ] around like that
you know and i'm wow i want them to go
go steal my neighbors like swing set for
a little while you know what i mean
swing set yeah well not like steal it
but like i would go i would go use it oh
oh i thought you like picked it up and
like walked out of the whole playground
no i was like [ __ ] ants are like
six years old and [ __ ] and like my
neighbors had a sick swing set and my
name is piece of [ __ ] it's six years old
you're not you're adorable like yeah but
i felt like a criminal was your neighbor
yelling at you you were no but they but
it was definitely too early i wasn't
supposed to be outside yet this was when
i was living in indy and then my parents
weren't even awake yet and so i would i
would like sneak out of the house go
play at my neighbor's house like in
their backyard before anyone was awake
yet yeah i was sick that was back when i
was an early bird
he's dead he's i'm murdering him no he
still wakes up early he's on the crypto
right away
i actually do actually he wakes up hell
earlier what time do you wake up bro i
get up honestly i get like seven now
dude when i was crashing at this place i
wake up early i wake up i go downstairs
she's already on the computer i'm like
oh [ __ ] what time do you sleep you sleep
i go to bed like two you only need like
five hours of sleep before honestly if i
get more than that i'm way too tired
it's not even fun yeah you get tired for
having eight hours of sleep i wish i had
yeah but he supplements on like 20 red
bulls so there you go
you're a liar
see where all these things went yeah
would you like all these nice people i
i'm just a pathological liar how do you
explain yourself to your parents yeah i
don't i don't they don't know i'm here
doing this right okay they shouldn't
really hope they don't steve's really
powered by that biden hack because he's
filled with inspiration is what it is
united states yeah legally
and you better get used to that's not
what i heard dude i heard i wasn't
getting used to it it was illegal he won
office actually i think he did it right
because his platform was
which i was like i'm voting for that
yeah
fool me once yeah
so people found out about this uh
[ __ ]
party because obviously people are
throwing it on social media [ __ ] 20
cars outside snapchat all these a bunch
of different things yet ironically
nobody was really caught convicted or
anything like that the police have just
put out notices saying that there are
like 200 people that ended up showing
here
if anybody's got information about
different people that blah blah blah you
know come forward with information they
bounced before the cops could even get
there when law enforcement arrived
partygoers left the scene they said
evidence from the party was easy to find
since those that broke and posted their
own evidence on social media yeah of
course they did yeah but like at the
same time it's like
there was like over 200 people there you
know what i mean
they're saying the police said videos
are circulating on snapchat instagram
and other social media platforms with
some of the highlights including where
some of the people attending turned the
four year of the 8 million dollar home
into a boxing ring
but the shares are now asking for those
who ransack the home to come forward
themselves before the evidence does it
for them oh interesting
what's crazy is those homes are so big
they could be on like multiple acres or
whatever so
it could have been way into the night
before any other neighbor even noticed
that anything fishy bro you could be
dude i've been in your house
i could be downstairs fighting [ __ ]
anthony in the living room with boxing
gloves on i'm knocking [ __ ] over you
wouldn't even [ __ ] know no but this
guy says he's got a neighbor who [ __ ]
come out and would just be like with
like [ __ ] a gun and [ __ ] and be like
who is that who are you
he's hardcore wait what he's from
mississippi well you were like you're
like you have a neighbor that'll come up
with guns pointed at you and you're like
he's pretty cool i like him he pretty
helps protect he protects and serves
dude right if it's not bart if it's not
geo it's like he's going to shoot
somebody no that doesn't give him the
warm fuzzies we're visiting his house
yeah i feel safe
i guess if it's not taika too
you gotta add taika in there he's
i was thinking about this the other day
like you know when we're like that age
right and then you have these like
events that you had to be there because
there was no [ __ ] cameras and the
only people that kind of know are the
ones that go out and then like tell the
story right so everyone that's listening
to this [ __ ] they're only like hearing
about what happened and then
now you could just see everything like
everything is just [ __ ] captured
right sure i understand oh really you
don't understand yeah me neither
listening because that [ __ ] is
everywhere now yeah but like
do you like that better where you have
to kind of like the imagination yeah
imagine when someone tells you the story
or would you rather just see the real
thing
i was boring as [ __ ] in high school so
i'd rather just see it because i didn't
go out anyway so let me tell you a true
story i was in fifth grade okay we were
we were having a party in basement my
friend's house a birthday party and it
was fun because we were all having like
a little fight club down there and when
you're in fifth grade you don't really
fight you sort of just throw each other
on the ground
start trying to kiss each other there
were a couple girls there
so we were just means it was real real
throwing the boys were trying
we didn't know what we would even do if
we got a girl naked but we wanted to try
right
so we were like throwing each other in
the ground and [ __ ]
and uh it was all really pathetic well
you're throwing the girls on the ground
no no each other dudes
the girls are watching so we're trying
like you know [ __ ]
girls and [ __ ] you know round one trying
to get a girl's attention by making out
with your best friend you know that's
how to get attention
but the legendary story
from this fifth grade party wasn't even
the fights or anything all that was
forgettable but my friend joel
he had an american flag in the basement
and he [ __ ] took down his pants
and he wiped his butt on the american
flag whoa and that is something that we
all remember it was the most extreme
thing i had ever seen you guys like you
just [ __ ] did blasphemy yeah
obviously i'm in a military family and i
was just like i was like you have to go
burn the flag now that's the craziest
[ __ ] i've ever [ __ ] absolutely seen
in my life would you rather start
pissing on yourself i do i just couldn't
even believe it you feel guilty like
what was that you all felt guilty well
we were like wow this guy's too far and
like that's the moment that got steve
green into comedy right now he stepped
over the line actually and i told no i
didn't do it
but no that was but like it's just funny
to remember like little stupid [ __ ]
thing like that yeah but like it's so
big
it's pretty extreme that's like
brilliant whoa that kid is like the
lenny because he also has a boy right
you know when you've helped like you
lead like pledges allegiance to that
like city council whatever it's like
don't let the flag touch the floor yeah
because then you have to burn it yeah
yeah and if i were to see that in fifth
grade that probably blow my mind too i'm
like yeah what well there's that oh my
mind there's that cat during oh god i
think a revolutionary war or some [ __ ]
and he wouldn't let the civil war he
wouldn't let the flag touch the ground
or some [ __ ] he's getting shot he wins
wins the medal of honor and wouldn't let
the fighters around this guy's [ __ ]
wiping his ass
you're just thinking about [ __ ] like
that
people have died for these colors yeah
yeah but it is but you are like
indoctrinated that way as a kid in
america you're taught all that [ __ ] 100
who's our generation oh well every
country is like that right yeah like
every country they're not going to let
their flags to ground that patriotism
it's like universal yeah and this guy's
colors don't run brother that's right
and yet it seems like a very american
thing to wipe your ass with a flag i
know right it is it is a very
patriotic expression of my freedom of
speech but it's so funny to think of
like this
fifth grade little ass little white ass
just [ __ ] rubbing his ass on a
pristine flag that probably got to kind
of plastic like four months prior to the
four or five i'm looking at other fifth
graders
it's just like stop the music like
everybody's like
a [ __ ] streak on my [ __ ] flag
for july 4th they [ __ ] hang it up and
they're like who cramped on it red white
and brown that's [ __ ] weird she's
like this these colors actually are kind
of runny
[Music]
you